welcome to this video playing dr
imperial from from Pakistan I think
let's see what we got here the two
nights defense and daya is playing
castling which is really just giving
away a pawn for for not much because of
this just winning winning time okay
let's see I think I can just take on
deform there is there is no real
compensation for that it's been a while
that I looked at this though that let
the main problem with this totally
incorrect gambits they are they are bad
but it still needs to be played so well
sometimes you um ya lose time over
trying to remember how you exactly need
to play it ok check yeah this is so not
much for wide but how to how to exploit
it I can go can go nite f5 to try to
exchange the night and protect you seven
this this could be one idea it's there's
some drawback to that
not sure well if it goes Bishop g5 I
have f6 a bit ugly but not much else to
do if he trades I want to go Bishop e6
we are no f 6m can go also f6 and King
f7 you have six I must play anyway I
could have played Bishop v6 I should
have played pictionary 6 then then
that's really over can you can take 27
and I'm just keeping my porn yeah i hope
i hope this wasn't serious in accuracy
oh it's very annoying if they get away
with with a rubbish opening like that
it's really just like that I mean to
call it something else would be would be
would be not right just giving up a big
central pawn for nothing okay can you
have seven now I need to get out of the
pin and maybe get n p8 rook e8 first on
Bishop c5 damn thats problem and
probably both good yeah probably just go
into d 7 or is there something better I
would like to get the Queen's of of
course it says would make things easier
but I think if I ok i go here i can give
the check maybe again a check on c5 so
just go to d7 intending Bishop c5 maybe
you can play Bishop f2 what I can also
take c2 which is not really a really a
big issue and a 70 m probably cannot
grab anyway
yeah sure that takes it too I don't I
don't see why not okay just be sure to
six now getting rid of some material
really it allows the [ __ ] traitor this
this is funny can't check check here
first so we transpose right into an
endgame here where I have two bishops
and end an extra pawn ideas we should be
five now very simple but it it limits
White's options considerably
you can maybe go to c5 the others this
is possible getting work to eat too I'm
to eat to here or should I should I
carry a seven not not clear now probably
drop in crowley this is just a good
square now let's see how to proceed cam
maybe g5g for a seven wasn't a very
strong pawn anyway we should be five
that was a Knight c3 this wasn't very
good
okay I wanted to go with h 5 g for
fighting hiding 4rm the foursquare
if it takes it Michael Bishop g4 am I be
sure before sorry
maybe you can and then play 93 okay
maybe I can first recapture okay time
one head take be too that's a bit
unfortunate 95 then there's also f6
hanging right away now that's that's not
great
and night before I can take this but
it's not it's not very very great Jim
this wasn't great yeah maybe I should
difficult should have allowed him to to
take take on a seven
yeah I know this position is just equal
but he will for sure play on time this
is clear
Jeff draw our third I just I just yeah
what can you do I just stay on g6 and
I'm not losing this against no one tip
of course black for fits on time no of
course yeah this was still a very bad
game my meme I mean not winning this is
really heartbreaking this is just chill
maybe I shouldn't take a seat or I don't
know i mean i'm just a pawn up i have
two bishops this is a total joke but i
don't win this we should be success may
be stronger i don't know it's it's all
good that the problem it all looks good
and yeah this is just how can you take
off at six yeah going into a lost end
game but ok i don't win it this is
totally justified to play all this
because i don't i don't use it I don't
use all those mistakes be sure the four
winds are okay this also should be good
maybe maybe I have some some improvement
here yeah it's always minus 3 by the
conch but I I do I never play Bishop f4
here which seems to be strong and then
rookie tool I don't understand why this
is so good I here okay Ruby four wins
apiece
Jim c5 is still good of course I mean
you can never lose it on position we we
have seen this we have seen this in the
in the game but he has of course over
with any winnings I guess it's just just
a total total draw so still on toad is
still not clear to me what term and we
can could have won a piece at one point
anti-air Quincy six is just shy I don't
know yeah yeah I'm a bitter a loss for
words four words that that didn't didn't
manage to put this away Bishop f4 is
also strong line what does it better see
move the rookie here this wins apiece
does not even have a square for the rock
I mean what's this and the deep bonus is
running yeah I probably found the only
way to not win it this is also an odd in
itself oh my okay thanks for watching